it's time for the lawn Jean Chronicle a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn Jean wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon Jean good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
Jean chrome scope Larry lisseur from the
CBS television news staff and John oaks
from the editorial board of the New York
Times our distinguished guest for this
evening is the honorable Harold E
stassen director of the foreign
operations administration how many
persons in the executive branch of
government have a bigger or more
controversial job than a director of
foreign aid but even this year an
economy minded Congress cut only three
percent from the vast appropriation he
asked for three and a half billion
dollars in foreign aid mr. stassen how
long do you think the taxpayers of
America will have to bear this burden of
money aid to our allies overseas I think
it will continue to reduce but in some
degree it is be necessary as long as
there is a grave Soviet threat in the
world well now this assassin several
senators have been saying that the the
present bill can be cut by fifty percent
or so because of previous unallocated
appropriations I'm sure there's an
answer that would you tell us what it is
yes the previous unexpended
appropriations are committed to the
building up of jet air forces and
various countries that takes a long time
to build them if we side today in this
Congress to help establish jet squadrons
in Spain it'll probably be four years
before that money is spent and that's
why there's always a big carryover of
unexpended and in many instances on
obligated money suggesting the two
billion dollars or so is simply waiting
to be spent isn't quite an accurate
picture no it's a matter of the what we
call the lead time the time it takes
from there when you plan with
Congress until you finally get the
forces in being or the technicians
established in overseas areas well mr.
Dustin how do you know what's doing any
good now your fellow Republican parents
Brown of Ohio has said that since
nineteen forty we've given over I think
50 billion dollars to our friends
overseas and we've got fewer friends now
a more enemies and we have I had before
as is true no it's not true of course
take for example the situation of
Germany and Japan to begin with they
were not exactly friends ten years ago
but the people are very friendly and
building strength together at the
present time and of course there are
disagreements and their criticisms at
times from other countries that's a part
of freedom we do not have the forced
agreement of the Soviet area but
actually there's a lot of friendship
around the world to the United States in
that connection I'd like to ask you what
you think of the policy that sometimes
advanced of using our economic strength
to influence the internal political
policies of the countries that are
recipients of our aids such as land
forcing land reform in Italy through our
economic aid or tax reform in France
that type of thing well you can should
not try to force internal can do that
it's a matter of persuasion that's right
it's a matter of how will the aid money
be used and how can it be effective in
that respect land reform better wages
for workers greater productivity a freer
exchange of goods between the countries
of Europe for example those are a part
of the way in which the free world can
be stronger and the conditions of living
be better and therefore in turn
communism have less chance mrs. Carson
has been quite a hassle in Congress over
some of the projected writers which have
been attached to the foreign aid bill
and one of them I believe now senator
nolan's is rather big but it does a say
in effect as I read it that the
president would have the right to
reconsider our membership in the United
Nations if Red China were admitted in
the coming fiscal year now do you think
he should sign the bill with such a
rider attached the writer doesn't really
go that far as it's now presented in the
committee it indicates that if that
eventualities should occur the president
should immediately consult with Congress
indicating it's a very grave situation
but I feel that in its present wording I
would recommend that the President
signed the program which would include
that writer well how about the writer
that goes along that would cut off
possible aid to Italy and France if they
don't don't join the European army EDC
well those those writers I do not
consider a desirable process but that
one too is informed such that we can
carry on with it and therefore when you
consider the alternative of either
reaching an agreement with Congress or
of not having the program clearly I
would recommend the president to approve
the bill and go forward with the program
do you think that type of writer would
have any actual effect in persuading the
French of the Italians to join EDC any
more quickly now in my judgment you do
not get results by laying down
ultimatums when you're working with
friends but I think that it's a matter
rather of persuasion will that apply to
the other rider to mr. Stice on the one
that forbids us to give any help to any
nation that signs a locarno type treaty
in the Far East which would might mean
Britain in case Britain entered such an
alarum that writer again in its present
form and we can work the program with it
and it is an expression of congressional
intent and so we accept it that way be
correct say I happy about it well I
rather be correct to say that it's been
my own observation not only in this
present work but through life that if
you're working with friends you get
farther by persuasion by talking things
through then you do by trying to give
all Tomatoes speaking your president
Stassen a lot of people in this country
do believe that if we stayed home and
just trade
in our own hemisphere we'd be better off
than giving money to people who don't
agree with this many times and who
possibly may not fight for us now do you
think we could afford to stay home and
save our money by no means that if you
did that what you would tend to do is
increase the danger that the Communists
would take over Western Europe take over
the Near East with all the tremendous
oil reserves there take over in Africa
are in the Far East if you let that go
on for a few decades then you really
face a rather gloomy outlook for America
and the Western Hemisphere in other
words you feel isn't actually a must
that we must expend this money in order
to keep communism from gobbling up these
countries of Rohan Larry here we are
with about one-third of the world's
total production of goods and services
we have a tremendous position of
leadership in the world and that carries
with it a responsibility unless we
exercise that leadership we abdicate and
when we abdicate we do at our own peril
now you have them attacked of course by
a former political associate of yours
with whom you certainly are no longer
associated named mr. McCarthy for
encouraging what he calls the blood
trade between America's allies and the
enemy meaning of course trade between
the free world MV and the Iron Curtain
eastern country would you care to
comment on on this question of east-west
trade or free unfree trade yes I feel
that unless you're to conclude that a
third world war is inevitable with all
of its Horrors and unless you take that
that hopeless attitude then you must
look for the way in which there's a
chance of developing a peaceful world
relationship over a period of years and
so that when the other free nations say
we want to trade in non-strategic non
warned
on armament goods in consumer goods and
consumer manufacturing goods that I say
that is a desirable process but it order
there's a chance that you move the whole
Soviet area and its people and the
pressure of its people toward peace
instead of war well to go a step further
do you think it would be wise to offer
the communist country some alternative
to direct aggression do you think that
if we offer to trade with them within
non-strategic goods that we might soften
them up in the future and make them less
aggressive that's right in other words I
think that the the basic policy that
secretary dulles has enunciated is right
you must keep before the Communists the
alternatives that if they are aggressive
if they are belligerent they will be met
firmly and with great force if they will
move toward peace for living peacefully
with the rest of the world then there is
an opportunity for expanded trade and
for peaceful relationship all the less
easily alter natives always have to be
there I said you said recently that our
trade with Russia was the lowest it's
ever been yes in the nineteen fifty
three in the atmosphere of the Korean
War picture the total trade was lower
than ever before the longest question of
strategic or non strategic trade do you
feel that our we in agreement in the
first place with our allies or nuns on
what constitutes non-strategic trade and
not entirely there are different views
of it it's hard to know just where to
draw the line we'll say everybody will
agree that a powder puff or a pound of
butter is to be classed non-strategic
and everybody agrees that all kinds of
guns and heavy machinery our strategic
then you come in between what about a
heavy farm tractor is that strategic or
not is that sort of things still under
negotiation that i right we are making
headway and we've talked just this last
weekend with the president of the
British port border trade matter of fact
I'm going to Paris tomorrow Sunday
rather to carry on the talks on each
bill hold any possibilities of switching
trade from
one region to another say taking it away
from Indochina and sending more to Latin
America where he recently has them
really a dance yes the program presented
to Congress has flexible authority on
the part of the president so that if
waiter needs arise like in Latin America
he can transfer some funds from one area
to the other that flexibility has proved
very successful in the past that's in
fact the way in which he carried on the
East German food package remember when
the riots occurred as we moved in
immediately with food packages that was
done under that transfer power to meet a
sudden emergency and meet it effectively
oh we still have a little time sir I'd
like to ask you one question just what
do you think would happen if we did stop
all this aid and saved our money again I
think you'd immediately increase the
danger of a another Great Depression in
America and of a third world war other
words after World War two after World
War one we didn't do anything like this
we didn't have a program in relationship
to foreign countries we pulled back and
in a single generation we had the worst
depression in our history and we got
World War two I feel that following
effective leadership in these economic
and security matters and the
humanitarian approach a technical
cooperation gives the best prospect of
economic success at home and security
for the United States in the world thank
you very much mrs. Desmond for your very
candid comment the opinions expressed on
the lawn Giancana scope were those of
the speakers the editorial board for
this edition of the Ranji no scope was
Larry lesser and John Oaks our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
Harold E stassen director of the foreign
operations administration